as time went on did you have an
opportunity to observe
uh how mr depp and miss heard interacted
with each other
uh at the beginning um oh you know
lovely dobby everything was great the
honeymoon period was on and there was a
yeah it was good i mean it was great
great to see johnny happy again amber
was you know
lovely charming
as he usually is you know
good as gold
and then things you know things started
to change amber started to change amber
started
getting a bit i would say a bit more
uh feisty
demanding you know
i could see that amber wanted to wear
the pants in this relationship that was
pretty obvious
and
what in particular made you think that
that you observed personally
um just just the way uh
you know if something wasn't quite right
or
uh
amber could uh amber could get a bit
frosty at the drop of a hat so as time
went on you know i could see them
i could see them change i could see i
could see amber change i could see
johnny getting quieter
uh we get into the car and nobody was
speaking
and you know just things started
changing changing amber started getting
a bit more
grumpy
did you ever observe any physical
injuries on this herd
never no
how about on mr down
yes
yeah it started off with maybe a
a scratch once in a while you know
a swelling but it get got more it got
more yeah i'm not talking he was marked
every every week or every two weeks but
yeah
he he he sustained mark's there
definitely he was getting married can
you generally describe for us what you
remember about the the marks you saw on
mr depp
yes
as i was saying
in the prison service you're taught to
pick up log in your mind mental mental
logging in your mind
marks bruises bully patterns stuff
what i noticed right away was most of
these marks and most of these things
through my training
is happening in the left-hand side of
his face
and it would be scratches on his neck
maybe a a fat lip in the corner
maybe a bruising on on the eye socket
um
dull impacts you know except for
obviously the scratches maybe on his
billy's left ear sometimes it'd be two
two marks two lines two charms
one
yeah you know
yeah
it was getting it was getting more
regular as i say not every week but it
definitely happened yeah
can we see um
plaintiff's exhibit
162 please
and mr connolly uh are you able to see
the picture on i assume you can see it
on your screen
yeah just
thank you please
yeah hi yeah
and do you uh
yeah i know that picture i took that
picture
you took pictures
yeah i took the picture
can you just quickly tell us what what
this picture is
this picture is a
misheard and johnny's
honeymoon
on the origin express
on the east line
from
bangkok
to singapore
you travel through malaysia stopping
kuala lumpur and a few other places on
the way down you just continue to
describe for us uh what we're looking at
in this picture
yeah as i said the guy in the bow tie
he's the guest relations manager he was
detailed to
you know
fixes up anything we needed
you know to excursions and transports
and stuff
then it's misheard
the guy that's the chef he looked after
this he looks he's he cooked for a
great chef by the way
yeah he looked after us and that's
johnny and i also notice if you look at
that picture
like i said
on the left hand side under his eye
there's a swelling
and you see a swelling just on the left
hand side of his nose and under his left
eye
and what do you interpret that swelling
to be
do what down what do i interpret as
that's uh
he's walked into a door
or a door's walked into him
okay
can you tell us anything and we can take
this down i think
thank you
uh mr connolly can you tell us uh well
first of all what uh
do you recall what year mr depp and and
miss heard went on their honeymoon uh in
the picture we were just looking at
um
that would is it i don't know 2013
2013
okay and were you uh well you testified
that you took the picture so you were
there i assume
absolutely yes um
what can you tell us about that trip
generally and particularly focused on
how mr depp and ms heard were
interacting with each other
um started off good started off good uh
johnny's cabin was maybe
15 meters down the corridor from maine
there was no cabins in between
there was a like storerooms like you
know blankets and cutlery and stuff
uh so
the cabin was quite
not a big massive distance but you know
it wasn't like
the this trip started flying absolutely
fine
i think it was five six days five days
maybe
two days three days at the trip uh
i can see johnny going down i can see
him coming down you know
uh
[Music]
he's just he's just not enjoying this
he's not enjoying us
but you know i can't it's not my
business to to step in than that i just
do my job but i can see he's not
enjoying this
like it's not he's not happy